(gentle music)
- At your first pre-natal
visit during your pregnancy
your provider will order a number
of routine pre-natal labs.
The term pre-natal means prior to birth
and refers to the time
period of your pregnancy.
It's helpful to know what you
will be screened for and why.
These tests will require a blood sample,
urine sample, and vaginal swab sample.
Some testing may have already been done
before you are pregnant during
a pre-conception appointment.
Your provider will check your blood type
and Rhesus type, or RH type,
which is a specific protein
on red blood cells that has implications
for the health of your baby.
Your provider will make sure
you don't have antibodies
to other types of blood
that could potentially
put your pregnancy at risk.
Your provider will get
a starting evaluation
of your blood level and platelet level.
This helps ensure that you're not anemic
or have complications that could lead
to dangerous bleeding during
your pregnancy or at delivery.
You will be tested to
see if you are immune
to German measles, also known as Rubella,
and if you are immune to Chickenpox,
also known as Varicella.
If you are not immune to either of these,
it will be especially
important to avoid infection
during pregnancy and you can
get a vaccine after delivery
to protect you in the future.
All women in the U.S.
are screened for HIV,
syphilis, hepatitis B,
chlamydia, and gonorrhea.
Some providers add tuberculosis
screening to this panel.
Women with risk factors
should also be screened
for hepatitis C and Trichomonas vaginalis.
For patients with other risk factors,
Zika screening, toxoplasmosis screening,
or herpes screening may also be offered.
Your provider will check to see
if you're carrying any
bacteria in your urine.
You may not have any symptoms,
but if you have any bacteria,
you will need antibiotic treatment
to prevent a potential kidney infection
during your pregnancy.
The American College of
Obstetrics and Gynecology
recommends all women be tested
to see if they are
cystic fibrosis carriers
or spinal muscular atrophy carriers.
If you are found to be a carrier,
your partner should also undergo testing.
Women who are at risk
of pre-existing diabetes
will be tested at the
beginning of pregnancy
and most women will then be tested
for gestational diabetes between 24
and 28 weeks of gestation.
Thyroid screening is not
recommend for all patients.
If you have any risk factors
or a history of thyroid disfunction,
your provider will recommend screening.
Your provider will offer you
a non-invasive fetal
genetic screening test
to determine if your pregnancy is high
or low risk for Down syndrome
or other genetic trisomy anomalies.
This testing is optional
and you have the choice
to meet with a genetic counselor
to find out more about it.
If you test positive, you
would then be given the option
for invasive testing such as with
chorionic villi sampling or amniocentesis
to diagnose if your pregnancy is positive
for genetic anomaly.
At 35 to 36 weeks gestation,
your provider will collect a vaginal swab
to test for Group B Streptococcus.
This type of bacteria can infect
your baby during delivery.
If you are a carrier, you
will be given antibiotics
during your labor.
As always, we encourage
you to ask questions
if you don't understand
why a particular test
is recommended by your provider.
Your healthcare team is here for you
working to ensure your pregnancy
is off to a healthy start.
(light music)